let's explore this notion of using
something other than actual physical
gold as a unit of exchange so let's let
me draw my balance i'm going to draw it
a little bit neater this time so i built
my building
my bank my vault whatever you want to
call it and i and i used
100 gold pieces to build it so this is
just my bank's balance sheet bank of
cell
so it's 100 gold pieces
and when i say 100 gold pieces this is
this is equity hopefully you're familiar
with it by now
but it's not like there's actually a
hundred gold pieces anywhere anymore i
took this hundred gold pieces paid the
builders of my vault looking temple
looking bank and maybe they lived
someplace else and they just took those
that gold with them so i'm just saying i
have a 100 gold pieces worth of a
building maybe if i had to sell this
someone else would give me 100 gold
pieces for them and that's why i say i
have 100 gold pieces worth of equity
anyway that's not the point of this
video
so i go i tell everyone hey you can keep
your money safe or your gold safe with
me so let's say that uh i don't know
citizen a
citizen say he says well this looks like
a a good bank and sal you've lived in
this village all your life and i trust
you and and your ancestors so i'm going
to deposit 500 gold pieces with you
so that becomes
an asset in the bank
500 gold pieces i'm going to try to
write as neatly as possible
got the width off a little bit but i
think you get the idea the width
shouldn't matter
the height kind of represents the
quantity
so this guy maybe it's my uncle 500 gold
pieces deposits in the bank because this
vault that i built seems a lot safer
and i say well
do you want it all in your checking
account sir or would you like some cash
back
and he says oh well how how i need some
cash you know to just transact every day
and and to buy
you know supplies or food etc so why
don't you put 400
equivalent in my checking
account so let me draw that
let me do the cash back first so let's
do say i do 100
cashback first so then i have this
liability here
of a hundred
so it's a hundred
gold pieces equivalent of notes
outstanding
no for notes outstanding
and maybe i just hand him
five
twenties for that
as most atms today do
but i just don't want to get confuse
things too much remember this is in my
fictional world these aren't necessarily
dollars just yet these are bank notes
from the bank of sal saying that anyone
who were to hand back one of these 20s
to me will get 20 gold pieces that's all
it says
and they're hard and i've signed them
and i've made them hard to forge just
because i don't want anyone printing
these notes and then coming to me and
getting my gold pieces i only want the
ones that i printed coming back to me
but anyway that depositor so he got a
hundred gold pieces of notes and that's
what i've drawn here and then the rest
will just stay in his checking account
so
checking account
it's a liability for me right because he
can he could at any point would draw
that checking account and get back 400
gold pieces
so 400 gold pieces for a's checking
account a's checking
call it checking deposit there's a bunch
of ways you could write it but this is a
liability for me these are my assets
fair enough
someone else who trusts a
says oh you know let's say let's call
them person b souls a if it's good
enough for a it's good enough for b so
let me put my money into this bank
account as well and i want to do a
similar type of transaction as a
although maybe they don't have as much
money so let's say that they have
i don't know let's say they have 200
gold pieces so let me draw that on the
left hand side first
so 200 gold pieces
from person b
that looks like about 200.
200 gold pieces and they want half of it
in
cash and half of it is a checking
deposit account
so let me do it like that so let's see
it's about
half of it will be
gold pieces for b's
account
and then
we also give him
some cash
which are essentially bank notes in our
current universe
and let's say he wants it all in 10 so
we give him
so let's say 100 gold pieces
gold pieces equivalent notes outstanding
and i'm going to hand him um
let's say he likes it all in ones i
don't know something he likes the weight
of the money
where he has to i don't know what he
does with the one dollar bills but a
hundred times
a
one gold piece denominated banknote
right i give them a hundred of these
fair enough
so let's explore a little bit about how
some transactions can occur with a and b
let's say a
needs to
buy an apple from b so
let's say let me draw this up here
i don't want to run out of space i'll
draw it actually down here so let's say
i have person a
and i have person b
so b has an apple
b has an apple
that's my drawing of an apple and person
a wants it and asked person b how much
is an apple cost and person b says well
an apple costs two gold pieces
so a person says well that's a little
high but i'm hungry so i will give you
two gold pieces for it but i'll tell you
what you know i've there's this new
thing called a bank and i don't have
gold pieces and and i think you know
what it's all about instead let me just
give you these pieces of paper that the
bank says at any time i can go and trade
for gold pieces
so person b says oh that's fair enough
i'm very familiar with that concept as
well so person a
person a gives person b so person a has
you know maybe they broke maybe they
maybe some of these weren't 20s maybe
some of these were
um
were two dollar bills or something or
let me just say they were one dollar
bill so one gold piece note
one gold piece actually let's just make
it since he got five twenties let's say
he gives them a twenty
he gives them a twenty gold piece note
i should draw it in green because that's
the color that i originally drew the 20
gold piece notes one of these he hands
one of these over to person b
b hands over
the apple to person a
and he also hands over
he also hands over 18 of those one
dollar notes that he got
so one dollar notes
right that these were these notes here
that person b got
hands over 18 of these one dollar notes
so times 18 and so the net effect is
that you had
two dollar notes switch hands and an
apple was exchanged and what's neat here
is a couple of things one no gold ever
had to exchange hands and gold is heavy
and you don't want to carry around a
bunch of gold you're able to do very
exact change uh in this situation and
you can imagine a world where gold is
worth you know 20 times uh your smallest
unit of exchange you want so it'd be
very inconvenient to have to break up
little gold coins in this case our small
you our smallest unit of exchange is
one gold uh dollar bill or whatever you
want to call it but you can imagine you
could break these up you could this bank
could issue
notes that are a quarter of a gold piece
or an eighth of a gold piece and that's
a lot easier than actually cutting up
gold pieces and then having to put them
all back together
and of course these notes can then
switch hands between people as as the
economy needs as it functions and the
bank doesn't have to worry about
anything and the goal doesn't have to be
moved around so everyone is happy
let's say that that
person b
actually wants to buy something large
from person a let's say person b wants
to buy
let's see person b
person let me let's person a is richer
so let's say person a is buying
something from b so let's say b is a
home builder all right let me do that in
blue
let's say person b is a home builder
and person a is going to get him to buy
a house and get him to build a house for
him so he's going to say well i'll pay
you 200 gold pieces to build a house
that's a huge amount of money i don't
like walking around with that how how
about i write you a check
and person b says well what is a check
well a czech person a says is i just
write you a note and that essentially
instructs the bank to transfer that
amount of gold pieces in my name to it
being in your name and personally says
oh well that sounds reasonable enough so
person b gives person a a home
works for weeks to build a house
and then person a
writes b a check
and now we're getting an introduction to
checks and the check will look something
like this
person b will fill person a will fill
out uh you know it'll have a's name
there and it'll say 200 gold pieces
please
and then a will sign it
a and probably date it you know 10 i
don't know 2008 and then give it to b
and then b can take it back to this bank
b can take it back to the bank and the
bank will do the transfer and all the
bank has to do is take 200 gold pieces
from here and put it there so this is
all the bank has to do really
right now 400 gold pieces in a's name
just take 200 of those
and put them in b's name
so now this is b share
b's new share
which would be 100 plus 200 so it's 300
gold pieces
and then a share has shrunk
to just being this part right here but
notice the bank didn't have to do
anything except a little bit of
paperwork
200 gold pieces and that was useful
because you didn't have to exchange cash
there's you know we talked about gold
being dangerous to keep at home because
obviously someone could steal it and
it's also inconvenient because it weighs
a lot it's hard to break up and carry
around if you're doing a lot of it but
cash is the same thing these banknotes
are also dangerous because someone can
steal them and no one's keeping track of
who has which banknotes so they can
there's still something that's very
stealable but a check was nice because
one you could write a very large amount
and also
only
if we're doing our authentication right
person a can write the check so it's not
like someone could in an ideal world
someone could not have stolen a's
checkbook and signed for him because
hopefully this bank has a signature on
record and can recognize when when a has
written a badjack or maybe they'll even
check with a to say if something is a
little bit suspicious
but anyway that's an introduction to
banknotes and checks in the next video
i'll talk about how we can use all these
notions to actually lend money also
without giving out any gold see in the
next video